previously on raft can we no longer
plant watermelon in a medium plot wait
you need seeds is that a seed or an
extra oh you're right oh I'm water right
right right right right right right okay
okay guys okay
I already harvested the whole left side
of the island
oh I had no idea I already did what is a
solid foundation we looked at this look
look how nice it looks beautiful leaves
go with seeds Mark are you done
organizing yeah
he's flooding back into me all right
don't go into the chicken coop all right
I'm gonna go see what's going on at the
Trading Post uh God I forgot about trash
cubes right and the trash can does not
make it the trash can just throws stuff
away no we need a recycler which is like
a thing you need a battery for it's like
we're not even close to having that
never mind can we make all that stuff
already the recycler is like a recipe
you get from a specific Island you have
to visit I think it might be this one
huh could be this one
could be this one that could be you're
not wrong I don't know why I'm dying
like this
I just can't stop now oh I can't like
Guru Herald on helium
the only way to live how would ever
anyone ever know about Guru Harold how
could they ever find out about smartless
I mean go my favorite sports team I mean
distractible I mean armchair expert
oh my God why did I come on to the
island I'm full I'm full now that's good
and we're bad just I think just good
okay that's good I don't know if there
are places for these things but I'm
emptying my butt into it oh [ __ ] there
is a problem okay so it's not the it's
not me upstairs that's blocking it it's
when you guys walk near it downstairs
but I'm thinking if I if I move this
might just be able to create like a half
wall I'm a genius I'm a genius I will
allow this I am a genius okay and then
by putting these here
we will have eggs soon I love eggs I
love eggs eggs are so nutritious people
people don't understand how good eggs is
I like eggs too eggs are so versatile
too how many foods can you make into
things that have that many different
textures and stuff I know scrambled eggs
I know fried eggs yeah Poached Eggs
boiled eggs various hardnesses or
softnesses mayonnaise which is basically
eggs being a success eggs do everything
I don't have a shovel and I want one
here I got it again here I'll fart one
out of my dick for you when I'm coming I
almost see that oh God rebirthing my
shovel oh shovel myself where are you uh
I don't know
I caught your dick shovel oh that
doesn't sound very good oh let me see it
is it beautiful
oh my God the shark behind you is very
interested in our dick shovel Apparently
that is that's much bigger shovel than I
thought it was I don't know how I passed
that that's incredible why is this meat
taking 10 years to cook steaks can you
cook faster please
oh okay your dick self is more important
than my meat yes
veto
too bad
no you don't get it that's the bad part
too if you do a double veto uh Kenny
veto I double dog veto pop can he veto I
mean we didn't establish that but he
would be also part of whom might
establish such a thing so I it's hard to
say wait are you establishing a veto a
global veto right now in our uh I
established my crypto of the vetoing
that I just vetoed
you're creating a dangerous precedent
here I just want to let you know yeah
veto I guess not
I don't think that I don't think that
works I don't think that works he vetoed
the precedent I did
the president of the United States
I also vetoed my own joke it was bad oh
dude oh
I'm sloven and there's a poor I don't
like either of them guys where or did I
just go that was strange I moved uh just
kill that boar these stuffs are easy
peasy my spear broke this will be fine
so we're stupid oh where I'm at on the
island wow I really shouldn't I should
not have picked up the cooking things
while they were cooking something
um
the steaks have vanished
um oh no why I just put all that
resources and time into those steaks oh
man Uh Oh I thought I had a cooking
table that I just made and I was like
I'm gonna play but it didn't fit is the
thing so I found out if you just stay
near The Boar's ass it can't hurt you
and it gets really angry
that's cool and if you stab him in his
butthole it's a One-Shot couch
you get it inside of his bath house
all right guys we have got we are almost
in business because as soon as I get
some Bulls we gotta freaking cooking
table going up here
water
welp
it's never the response I expect you
know I always think it's gonna be some
kind of like wow that's great but isn't
it why is it all about you yeah why
isn't it it's not about me that's what
I'm complaining about process what
you're saying the moment like I'm here
like oh I have a response Bob has
something horrible happened bathtub all
right I'm I'm coming home I'm coming
home I'm coming home
I'm coming home how do I make a bowl
clay
oh wait a minute a classic saying make
the bull by the horns oh this guy our
tail is the hottest time hey how do we
make mushrooms I have mushrooms you need
mushrooms uh put it in the food chest
don't eat them I'm gonna figure out how
to make more of them the birds don't
seem to want to go to the nests it might
just be because we're not moving but
although that was code
the birds have not entered the nest
oh okay do we have any clay
yes awesome
that's all I know seven dry bricks in
one of the chests all right
though so if you guys can keep
the grill wooded we're pretty much
running out of wood every time we stop
we run out of wood I can go cut a tree
but I don't know I cut a bunch of trees
now but it didn't give me that much wood
yeah it's kind of inefficient
I don't know why we have a lot of a
waste wow two raw steaks I would love to
cook these but I'm terrified Mark will
take them away okay you can never let go
flat don't flat go with me
last time you've let go okay you know
what I don't want to flood go
all right hold on then hold on here I
hate your anger maybe I will all right
maybe you should uh we've done on this
island I definitely never explored at
all I'm busy as the only Island Explorer
it's a slow process I can tell you the
designated Explorer of islands oh [ __ ]
also we're not done on this island oh
wait I already went through this whole
Saga never mind ignore what I was about
to say repeatedly guys I'm getting older
that's the theme of today's rap
if you want to understand that reference
you should listen to distractible any
episode will do literally everyone
involves a reference to that experience
I need to get some trash cubes can we
make Trash cubes
what happened Mark
nothing nothing happened I just did the
shark take one of them oh my God I got
angry I got angry and I I hit it really
hard oh you destroyed our eyes [ __ ] I
know sorry eventually I'll make the cook
food upstairs because I'm gonna I'm
gonna make another chest and make it for
like just pure cooked food you do that
right now actually
[ __ ] all the food cuckold the food wait
what sorry I've only read that word I've
never heard it said out loud
assumed it was pronounced [ __ ]
turn next to Whole Foods oh hey there's
a thing up here look at that I got a
handy and the vine goo somebody was
wanting some of those yeah someone
someone indeed are you mad at that
person
someone did
some I'll find out who okay I'm sorry I
brought it up I didn't mean to uh okay
I'll help I can help you guys I'm gonna
have so many planks awesome you didn't
even know how many planks I'm about to
have flanking for a spanking yeah I
don't think he would I don't want to so
I hope not all right well tough crowd
tough crowd this island has so many
islands of it a rat of it in it around
it I don't know you know what I mean
no I don't actually either neither
neither nor that's the point for
Gryffindor
[Laughter]
what do you think you are I'm your
friend no it can't be
it was me the whole time soup is
currently uh being uh made upstairs I
highly recommend you uh partake it's a
beautiful vegetable blend you can't
bring it to us soup kid's afraid to
leave it I will throw your ass out into
the ocean
[Laughter]
oh dear oh my God I'm actually full of
planks
guys yes yes yes whoa soup is balling I
know I remember why you made so much of
it yeah soup is dope definitely
definitely soup soup Fox you can tell
Soupbox just by looking at it but when
you see it [ __ ] want to give you that
extra bit of soupy goodness on top of
your eat bar when you look it in the eye
while it [ __ ]
if you're if you're if that if you're
into that yeah yeah who would be me
Bruno
okay
[Laughter]
Bruno he's so ugly don't look at him no
Bruno's that SCP where if you look at
him he'd die SCP you mean the back room
oh yeah those back rooms yeah sorry the
back room entity
I apologize backroom entity Bruno
everybody knows that that's cheaper you
know bib
don't look at bab bad
uh I'm sorry is that beb2424
oh yes absolutely you you know about
babe you read the beb archives bro I
Can't Get Enough oh nine seven beat
yeah he he thinks he's a Bevin but he
ain't Bevan I was bubbling
guys
I got a shark eating oh I hear a shark
at me I'm trying to kill it in the
middle is that one of them is turkey I
killed it I killed it you guys are a
shark eating
Shark dead it's metal cut I was I was in
the midst I was betwixt things hang on
in the middle I need to make like a
raised platform I think that's where
it's got to be or maybe I'll just start
on the second floor I don't know I don't
know man
okay I got some clay got some sand
getting some metal
[Music]
oh this is copper
it's a copper
you what do you you mark oh
okay
you good man he stubbed his seagull or
something oh you silly cow
[Music]
sounds very nice I can smell your bones
okay I'll see him
okay
[Music]
sounds like that look at that like a
deep throat if you know what I mean
what's it called a blowfish Blowfish a
dick indeed a dick into you know a dick
in me wait no
where the road gets rather head
a thousand miles from your own bed
[Music]
thanks I'm glad you finished it really
wouldn't have had the same impact if you
hadn't gone all the way to the end there
isn't really as good if you don't go all
the way
you
yeah yeah you know kind of Louis
Armstrong I don't know why Louis why is
Louis singing this one I thought the
shark was dead
well he he was a long time ago oh he's
not anymore ow guys I know where the
shark is yeah
I need oxygen
hey I'm gonna die over here off the back
of the raft if someone wants to come
save me here I don't see nothing over in
the ocean hey oh all right stick a stick
oh that really got you yeah good thing I
have fins
crap how do I how do I get you I hear
you holy yeah
oh thanks bud you're real jiggly
I am
well you should have known
the shock is inside me you want some
soup
uh yeah
pouring soup on them you want uh you
want the soup
before I came out here and that was a
mistake yeah soup upstairs you get soup
up there soup in the Box come get your
soup out of the box box is that two
soups Johnny
oh don't mess with my soup
I got a restaurant now I don't know if
you want to know that reference you
should listen to distractible too
distractible for free on Apple podcasts
and Spotify today featuring over 70
episodes starring Mark Bob and wait Rush
delivery available 30 days
oh we have fun there and not here so go
there one person
people promote things I'm never going to
listen to it just because they tell me
it exists what is that what are you
talking about what happens is not
listening out of like
right I have seen that which I think is
hilarious because everyone else who said
that have been like yeah I finally tried
I enjoyed it and that one person's still
like no no I'll only watch this with
them nothing I enjoy their content but
not the content they promote I enjoyed
the content I've got good news guys
we got double ovens upstairs we got
double the soup production
soup out years
and soup out my ass it's some kind of
horses
I'm drowning
this voice is not good for us guys can I
just say that it leads us to think
things are funny in our brains but then
when it comes out we realize what's
happened uh voice is misleading I have
yet to realize how awful my comedy is
by yourself like that come on bud thank
you yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh [ __ ]
yeah it's a rat oh [ __ ]
why were you that mean man do you even
know that Meme I don't know what you're
talking about there's uh I mean yes the
meme meme
what happened over there Grandpa where
have you been
under the water trying to find blunder
Desi then nothing has happened
at all I choose to believe you at face
value and have no further questions I
hope you weren't too attached to those
steaks Wade again
laughs
[Laughter]
should I still be grabbing seaweed oh
yeah okay we're gonna need a lot of Goo
for gear
you don't have to mock him when he's
saying something actually he's just
mocked you it's not very nice who would
do that I don't know mocking me who
would come up with some kind of voice
and mock people for just
I was expecting it still made me laugh
like in a genuine way the setup was so
obvious from 10 miles away everyone was
like he's gonna do it until he gets mark
it really does I'm just it is quite
pathetic and I realize it but yeah
I wish I
had a better joke than that I gotta be
honest but if it works I'm gonna keep
doing it it's a solid joke it's a solid
joke not like awful I don't feel good
about it yeah you shouldn't I mean I
feel good about it for you
okay I feel less good see it doesn't
feel good feels bad to me feels bad to
everyone else involved not a good joke
everyone listening at home they're like
oh I feel so bad
it's funny but still
it was Jupiter in retrograde I don't
have a chance today
I don't know why everyone at home is
looking at their horoscopes I just
imagined that they were no no that's
accurate that's accurate that checks
ever I never expected the uh astrology
burn
so that is astrology and astronomy is
the real one ah yes yes I'm sorry was
that a bird I didn't did we not all know
that I didn't I thought we were helping
them
who
them
I'm ominous those those nope
[Music]
oh God uh rocks
what do I have
are they rocks red melon recipe recipe a
recipe that can be made in a juicer oh
yeah give give give give give give we
have a juicer I have a juicer up here
okay I'll bring it give give give give
one more blowing the hell is our raft I
feel like I've been expecting it to be
right around the corner though a long
time now hello
I'm here I'm I'm thirsting I'm dying of
the Thurston yeah we all are oh but it's
okay I can die because I found a blowy
why do you guys need so much blowy I
mean how do you think I stay awake for
so many hours in a row oh no come on we
were blowing how did you blow when I was
blowing [ __ ] you even out of context I
know what you're talking about that made
me sad
the sad music just started on my game
right when you said that
this really says when I die you guys
can't find my body because I'm [ __ ]
out there are you in the ocean or what
what are you doing oh yes I've been
looking oh I'm drowning and dying of
thirst at the same time it's a horrible
combination why are you out there
I've been trying to get Blowfish we need
the explosive goo for stuff I don't even
remember what we need it for we will we
don't not need it but it's not like we
need it desperately right at this moment
I don't think yeah why aren't I at the
surface there we go uh where is the land
I mean I'm on the land but where's the
raft
why can you how far did you guys go I'm
just circling the island harvesting like
I think I see the Traders Hut I got
that's the right place I must be close
to home I've got like there's
there's a tippy top now and I've got a
flag waving
nape that help I don't know if I'm gonna
make it but I see the raft it's
beautiful thank you ooh where where
where don't do it oh it did it
well the raft has slowly been being
eaten away because I am very bad at
defending it I hate to say it guys I am
now also dying of thirst and also
heading towards the Traders Hut you guys
want some soup
yes plenty of super oh wait do I have
soup no I don't have two you make sure
next time use go out you get some soup
oh I'm gonna put that recipe in here
Mark so now you get the recipe if you
want it please keep expounding oh that's
the end of the expoundation if you want
to understand that reference you should
watch distractible yes the hilarious and
toppley rated and once beat Joe Rogan's
very own podcast for a single day
true it's so true
suck it and everyone remembers that that
happened and with you's guys's help you
can make it happen once more oh red
melon interesting hmm
that would probably make that we have
berries right I'm gonna steal the all
the fruits from down there and bring
them up well the smoothies are nice uh I
think they give you the same green bar
on your your drink meter but they are
intensive to make just because they they
need a battery we actually have a lot of
metal I honestly think we might benefit
from cruising around just trying to get
planks yeah we haven't been cruising for
a while should we cruise lines I think
we should cruise boys
the anchor is weighed
uh no I'm not
sounds like the angers Wade no no no
guys come on it's not me I heard rumor
that anchor might be weighed not like
this I'm pretty sure anchor Wade
there's the dirt we have 11 dirts I was
digging some holes what does dirt do
uh gross plant you cannot make the pins
for animals oh so if we could make the
if we could make the one gun we could go
capture that goat that was on the island
capture the gun you need to make a net
shooting gun and then a net charge
that's what you need the explosive
goofar and then you capture a goat and a
net and then you put a goat and a pen
and the Pen's made with dirt you need
the gun to capture the goat first calm
down man somebody's gonna be okay okay
okay okay
I might not be you're right now I know
it might not be okay hold on hold on
again you need the pen if you're gonna
have a goal but you need to make that
make that you're gonna capture the go
but the gun shoots the explosive net
charges the it's gonna have the Nets and
their gun and the pen pen what are we
talking about I don't know what are we
talking about uh Sean Penn
no we don't have any strawberries I
can't make this God
I'm swimming towards the shark to get
the barrel this will all be worth it
oh he got my asses I jumped out of the
water
oh yeah there's so many waving cats
because they're cool I need where'd my
glass go
they were in they're in here they're in
here the old food chest yes you guys
want some pina coladas oh getting down
in the rain or something yeah getting
down in the rain
and having sex in the rain
[Music]
oh God not that one
I don't think you can destroy those I
think those are literally indestructible
oh good no don't panic that's the whole
I'm pretty sure that's the whole point
of those these [ __ ] are not giving
any eggs I don't think that's how you
get eggs
nest and then they get there but you
just gotta not leave them anyway they
got to be left alone for a while but I
had to jump down to get the shark and
then I think you get eggs by having a
chicken pen because I remember there
being a lot of eggs in our pen of
chickens that we had at one point I bet
those birds do lay eggs but I bet
chickens lay eggs more better good
probably you might be onto something
there maybe but I just gotta leave him
alone I keep checking them anyway
there's another island in the right
flying two or sailing plum
buddy oh man you need some water or
something
it's getting that Ocean map
oh
[Laughter]
I feel embarrassed that Mark didn't
laugh the way that I did but I was funny
man here I was sneezing with you I
snoozed wait say it again say it again
the sea is the cruel mistress but we
[ __ ]
oh ah he must have sneezed again I think
oh yeah you must have been sneezing or
something man these these uh these
smoothies probably not worth it they
take a lot of resources but it sounds
like they really do but you're making
smoothies which is cool you know it's
cool it's cool bro I like the way that
I've never seen it work before yeah oh
yeah oh you got a whole five-star
culinary experience up here yeah man
Marcus getting too into the cooking his
his veggies are all done growing and
he's ignoring oh they just they must
have just been sitting there withering
on the very bikes
that's good really unnecessary
no no
okay
honestly that wasn't even the mocking
voice that was uh what's that guy in
Family Guy that's what you sound like
long long bottom oh the guy who uh
Neville they they meet repeatedly and
they're like he doesn't talk but he's
all that's not Neville
[Music]
he might be that's true I'm watching
these birds they better
start plowing each other I can't do it
while you're watching man I'm watching
them all right we're loaded up on suit
my guys
so I know you got really into the
kitchen Thing Mark if we ever set up the
computer
right
okay look we've been we've been
accumulating resources I'll give that to
us and I don't I don't blame you don't
do it there we go
but I'm just I'm just saying maybe we
should get the navigations going and and
uh just maybe
if I kill this shark are you guys ready
to gather some underwater resources yes
yes no
she said I lied I'm not ready okay these
Dead Boys I'm glad we talked this
through and planned it out it's fine I'm
ready it's fine it's fine I'm ready I'll
stop being ready it's time I'm ready I
don't know what we need from underwater
other than I definitely need to find
more Blowfish let me use clams for I
keep grabbing them about what the hell
we use them for nests nothing no nests
see you can Nest it up like Nest like
the cameras or Nest like for birds like
birds
I cannot even tell which of you is
making that sound oh come on that's an
insult to me how would I make that no no
all the time you would use your mouth no
yeah
I don't know why I said that with no
confidence because it was in fact true
oh okay so it wasn't coming out of your
mouth I understand how you made it now I
farted that's probably not it that's
probably not it but I starved he's sure
he's starving he's about to show you new
other people but me sharved I'm gonna
shower to death we're not Blowfish in
this particular Island why where I don't
know how many how many those are
spawning in 2B there's usually like
three per Island and I [ __ ] up a few
of them on the last time which I don't
want to talk about I mean this island
too small it's a pretty good size and it
looks it doesn't have a trading post
though you guys we're never gonna get
planks if you keep going on every island
you see because we don't have any more
blanks mark this island had 35 Planks on
it how that's impossible trees trees
those don't exist
ah you got me
that's I do yes I do wow I'm kind of far
from the island I did not uh I'm fine
that happens quickly here for some
reason I'm getting under towed away good
uh good good bad glad sad bad dad you
okay so glad sad my dad I confused
undertow with camel toe I'm getting
camel toed away
[Laughter]
ah help don't help though I'm fine I was
very confused when you said it because I
was like what what the [ __ ] are you on
about
oh
that that is what happened in my head oh
silly silly silly
so silly
you silly cow oh this is a smaller
Island than what I thought it was gonna
be when we got here whoa easy there but
have we had any journals because uh I
got the journals from the places you
navigate to
[Music]
what happened to you
which one of us either
yes oh hey the shark's back guys yeah
you want to know how I know that because
I said it too much no I don't listen to
you okay all right oh he's gonna get my
parts
oh the bad ones or the good ones depends
thanks but why are you not making goo
what's all the we don't need this much
not too much copper I have too much of
it so I have to burn it to get rid of it
what did it do it's okay if you make but
I got too much ingots and I didn't want
more than one stack of the no nothing
gets I got too much or I need to get rid
of some of that or what the what the ore
yeah I've got extra oars look look here
one more extra ore and I got two more
extra ores go I just grabbed them I put
them right back in a different place
you'll never find them I did I found
them they will never find them why were
they there that was terrible well I wore
them there well you were terrible you're
terrible
[Music]
why can't I make that
bolt craft
and then
and then bam and then bam I've done it
Wham
do we know is it five or six sand uh
bricks to make a Torino I don't know is
six dry blocks well poop on my face you
know as they say
who says that
they
[Music]
um
charve on my face it's more of a modern
thing can we go get some more wood why
are these pit stops we need sand the pit
stops of these ah wrong altitude oh God
no are you trying to sit at the computer
Mark yeah it's it's the uh these
freaking antennas they have the antennas
have to be on the same level as the
computer and let's play but did you
declare your sand I got what I needed
without your help Jesus Christ wow face
mom phase mom not a phase mom Oh I
thought it was like you know part of
FaZe Clan you know FaZe mom FaZe mom
FaZe mom
hey man
you just calm down I wasn't mocking him
I was imitating him it's okay man it's
okay
[Laughter]
the invitation is a form of sort of
thing
caused me to [ __ ] myself
[Laughter]
all right I think we can leave now but
we are out of sand you're out of sand
I'm about to die this whole car room's
out of sand
objection uh soup
you want to enjoy a job well done here
why don't you oh here wow
and then take one of these and let's
cheers to that my Bros all right good
well done wait that's not the thing
there it is there it is
I'm so hydrated don't Point your salmon
gun at me
Sorry God that's still never never
doesn't get me you know what I mean oh
yeah
all right I'm weighing the anchor it's
away oh it's been all right how much
does it weigh it's a way or away I don't
know which one means what all right we
sailed right into the Ryan you guys got
they don't have eggs yet
where's your eggs the uh wind is blowing
us directly into the island eye do we
have any scoopers Mark you got your
scoop yeah one second oh I found a way I
found a way actually we don't need the
scoop we're going God I found a way so
we're gonna need to make a sweep net to
get bees so we can get honey I remember
that yeah
hold on I'm gonna get this one second
that's for a biofuel you think we're
gonna get biofuel yes
oh okay done it before and we're at
least as dumb as we were before at least
I think it's definitely guaranteed we're
more dumb than we were before well let's
make a net launcher but how do you make
them I used to give a [ __ ]
where are the Nets
it's been tools probably yeah yeah but
where's the net at the bottom of the
tools one there's a sweep net which is
the world
are you looking for the Nets that go on
the ship no I'm looking for the ammo for
the net launcher I got it we got a
signal boys we got a signal oh holy [ __ ]
[Music]
thank you